[Music]
pregnant Kate Middleton is pushing
through her acute morning sickness I
think it's pretty impressive the Duke
and Duchess of Cambridge received a warm
welcome on Monday from this cuddly
character Paddington Bear
[Music]
Kate who is expecting her third child
with Prince William was spotted dancing
with the adorable storybook character at
his namesake train station in London the
35 year old royal was not expected to
attend the event but appeared to be in
good spirits during the cute two-step
last month King sanctum Palace announced
the exciting baby news they also
revealed Kate was battling the same
illness she experienced while pregnant
with Prince George and Princess
Charlotte they're not all superheroes
you know and there's a little pressure
on parents and most of it is self-made
from Paris themselves when you feel you
have to better handle everything the
outing comes just days after the Duchess
debuted her baby bump at World Mental
Health Day it's good to see Kate
powering through her pregnancy while
looking pretty in pink
[Music]